sie fahren zurück in die ukraine zurück
nach hause frauen und kinder die vor
drei monaten vor dem krieg geflohen sind
immer mehr machen sich auf den weg in
die heimat sowie sascha
mitte mai habe ich angefangen nach
zugtickets nach kiew zu suchen aber sie
waren ausverkauft bis mitte juni
sascha kommt aus der hauptstadt am 25
februar hat sie ihr land ins ungewisse
verlassen nun geht es zurück eine lange
reise 24 stunden von warschau über
lemberg bis nach kiew
ich bin sehr aufgeregt weil ich mein
zuhause so sehr vermisst habe aber ich
bin europa auch sehr dankbar dass sie
uns aufgenommen und akzeptiert habe
sie reiste von land zu land auch nach
deutschland in berlin kam sie bei
freunden unter endlich war sie in
sicherheit ist das nicht schön ja wie
fliegen flugzeuge noch ein friedlicher
himmel
die frauen hier wissen dass sie sich zu
hause nicht so sicher fühlen können
saschas freundin die an der front
kämpfen haben sie aber überzeugt jetzt
zurückzukommen
am anfang hatte ich große sorge
unter dauerstress
aber jetzt haben mich meine freunde so
sehr beruhigt dass ich es nicht mehr bin
auch swetlana kehrt zurück wir treffen
sie auf durchreise in lemberg sie ist
mutter von drei kindern floh nach
deutschland und hat alles dafür getan um
dort bleiben zu können
[Musik]
wir haben anderthalb monate lang
dokumente gesammelt meine kinder sind
zur schule gegangen ich hatte auch schon
einen job gefunden hat dem ersten juni
wir waren registriert hatten bankkarten
aber dann haben wir ein schreiben
bekommen
darin stand sie müssen ihre wohnung
verlassen
sie sei zu groß für vier personen
niemand half ihr zu verstehen wie es
jetzt weitergehen könnte
dann haben wir unsere sachen gepackt
mein mann hat gesagt ich will nicht dass
ihr plötzlich auf der straße sitzt auch
wenn es hier gefährlich ist und gepumpt
wird wenigstens wissen wir dass wir ein
zuhause haben wo uns niemand raus
schmeißen kann
sie wollten es wirklich in deutschland
schaffen doch die bürokratie hat sie
mürbe gemacht erzählt sie uns
hart woanders zu leben so weit weg von
zu hause
mein mann ist in der ukraine und alle
anderen auch ich
habe ihn und mein land vermisst in
deutschland hatte ich niemanden
in wenigen tagen wird sie ihn endlich
wieder sehen die lange heimreise geht
morgen weiter die nacht verbringen sie
in einem hotel in lemberg
sascha ist inzwischen in kiew angekommen
und betritt zum ersten mal seit drei
monaten ihre wohnung
endlich bin ich zu hause
kurz nach ihrer ankunft schlagen wieder
raketen in der stadt ein
ich habe die raketen nicht gehört weil
ich so tief geschlafen habe sie sind im
osten der stadt eingeschlagen und ich
lebe im westen
es fühlt sich anders an als vorher die
stimmung in kiew ist nicht mehr so
panisch wie in den ersten kriegswochen
deshalb habe ich mich auch nicht mehr so
gefürchtet
auch wenn es eine sperrstunde gibt und
die preise gestiegen sind trotzdem ist
das leben zurück sagt sascha
am hauptbahnhof von lemberg ist es
ruhiger als noch vor einigen wochen als
alle nur raus wollten weg vom krieg es
gibt nun weniger schmerzvolle abschiede
für swetlana und ihre familie sind es
nun noch einmal 24 stunden reise bis
nach die nitro im südosten des landes
dann sähen erika und elisabetta ihren
vater endlich wieder
wir möchten jetzt nur noch so schnell
wie möglich nach hause und dort in ruhe
leben auch wenn immer noch krieg ist
werden wir hoffentlich mehr zur ruhe
kommen
nur ein bisschen ruhe das wünschen sich
svetlana sascha und so viele andere
ukrainerinnen